[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment news i'm
heather ruse and i'm anna wave and this
is your news for Monday January 1st
Happy New Year hopefully you've had a
good Christmas or holiday break if you
thought your family was crazy well let's
get into our first trailer that we got
to see this week called mom and dad
which starts Nicolas Cage and selma
Blair as a couple of crazy parents that
go on a killing spree yeah it sounds
like every parent in this sort of town
or neighborhood kind of gets these
homicidal rage going on and decide to
kill their children kind of almost
zombie style but they seem to still have
like a self-possession to them right and
a consciousness that he normally
wouldn't get in the zombification right
really scary really creepy there was
Nicolas Cage being his oh just the kgs
bonkers bonkers jazz singing hokey pokey
and layin sledge-hammering yeah like oh
my good classic classic Nic Cage
oh my god we only have to wait until
January 19th yeah right and it's
supposed to be a comedy like it yeah
that black comedy which i think is a
great marriage of material and man and
lucid and Nicolas chaos like it just
seems like he got permission to go
insane with this role and he did cuz
he's gonna do that anyway so right yeah
I'm looking forward to that
anything not Jeff nice and it seems kind
of funny though yeah that's true yeah
let me know January 19 yeah another
highly anticipated show that movie
coming soon is Black Lightning
part of the new addition to the CW flare
overs and they have a quick ten-second
new teaser trail teaser that came out
that showed him basically just punching
people with some Lightning oh yeah look
what he does and I'm actually pretty
excited for this right now it seems like
it's gonna be something that's just
totally different from anything else
that we've seen on the CW in terms of
the flare over right now absolute it
seems like it would be a strong addition
to the team because you have the serious
arrow flash which is a little bit it's a
great mix between the humerus and the
serious and then Legends which is just
insane it embraces the in Santa oh yeah
so Black Lightning seems as though it is
going to be a good addition to the team
I'm gonna probably check that out it
premieres on January 16th yeah also this
week FX has ordered a full season from
Ryan Murphy of the new series OHS now
this is going to be a musical anthology
drama set New York in 1986 and I I mean
but doesn't that sound amazing
I'm very good I did for this it's going
to be hopefully just amazing costumes
and amazing music cuz like right off the
bat like everyone's really into the
eighties right now you know it's the
things 2018 we're back in the eighties
so I'm very excited for this also it's
making history by having one of the
largest LGBTQ casts ever right now they
have a lot of reoccurring characters
that are trans actors and I think that's
incredible for FX to be doing so I'm
really looking forward to seeing what
this whole series is going to have in
store for all of us it's I'm looking
forward to some things I can maybe sing
along to maybe who knows yeah no way no
way to know yeah yeah so that will come
out in the summer of 2018
all right also this week we also got to
see the Doctor Who Christmas special and
the
brilliant regeneration of the doctor
from Peter Capaldi to Jodie Whittaker
and oh my goodness I am so excited for
her in the doctor I there's gonna be so
many things that can happen with her in
this little bit that you can see on line
spoilers skip a few seconds if you don't
want to hear ya watch it and then come
back but in the clip that you can see on
the BBC's You Tube we see that she now
becomes the doctor's body and is
forcefully ejected from the TARDIS yeah
so so many things can happen in this
next season of her looking for the
TARDIS making friends and companions and
just so many possibilities and oh my
goodness the open possibilities I'm very
much excited for this it'll be a great
new season yeah it was a good send-off
for Peter Capaldi as well honestly the
whole time watching him and his last
moments I could only imagine how much
fun he was having of just okay Peter
Capaldi if you could do your monologue
you've got the charges to work with and
go of just running around and turning
around and falling over and just
delivering an epic just final moments of
the doctor how fun must I have face I
would love to just run around a TARDIS
and deliver in my log Michaels 2015 I'm
talking about how you should be kind yes
he says kind of like a log trying to get
the hint so be kind listen to the doctor
doctor's orders
behind me nice yeah - all to 2018
resolution that's right add it to your
list this week we also got a first look
at bumble bees the movie like the
transformer yeah I actually was excited
at first you know okay bumblebee movie
movie but I'm a little hyped because
he's actually a yellow beetle Volkswagen
yeah yeah I'm so excited I'm like this
is the way he's supposed to be Thanks
we'll see what else happens with the
but at least he's a yellow boy it was a
cool look to it we got away Hailee
Steinfeld yes he was gonna be the lead
human dress in this which I have to
clarify obviously right bumblebee it's
not human right right but it'll be
interesting to see what they do with
this because transformers aren't really
discovered until later and right set in
1987 and apparently he's broken
bumblebee is broken he's in a junkyard
and then Hailee Steinfeld's character is
going to come and fix him and apparently
it's gonna be a bonding experience and
it's gonna be a heartfelt story of man
and machine the age-old tale the tale
it's two broken things healing each
other
well so I guess we can't really look
forward to any big battles because I
don't know again it'll be interesting to
see how they treat it right we don't
know in this world about transformers
until laters row no that should be
interesting yeah he'll be like memory
wipers men in black'''s aha yes whining
a little bit of Will Smith and just like
a little bit just a light refresh yeah
and that'll be coming to us sometime in
2018 yeah we don't quite have a release
date for it yet but 2018 bumblebee the
movie look forward I guess it'll be
there what a great review also this week
Black Mirror dropped its fourth season
on Netflix and as it dropped the fourth
season they released it's not really a
teaser trailer so much as it is kind of
a review yeah yeah hyped of what's
happened in the past but it's an
anthology series though there's not much
to review realm but the way that they
did it is they took real news clips and
stories from 2017 and integrated it
together with some past episodes of
Black Mirror so it starts off mostly
being 2017 news stories and then they
to blur the line and then it goes strip
strictly into the black mirror were you
but the way that they did it is of
course very black Mary oh yeah creepy
and a little unsettling and it's all to
this backdrop of happy music of Happy
New Year Happy New Year look at all
these horrifying things that have
happened happy new year that actually
happened yeah what a year so that is on
Netflix right now I've only stream the
first two episodes you said you have I
haven't seen anything for yet but that's
what I'm going to be doing on my holiday
break okay what is everyone else
streaming during holiday break I've been
really recapping on miss Fisher's murder
mystery because I'm behind on the game
on that show okay it was amazing yeah
yeah Luke and I might finally finish
strangers so let us know in the comments
down below what you will be streaming
and if you will be streaming black we're
just let people know that there's
boilers in your comments yeah we're
going into them but oh my goodness
there's but also it's also in an
anthology so like you're not really
spoiling more than an episode at a time
yeah you know yeah first episode those
at Star Trek e1 and you should watch
because I can't wait I've heard great
things also there might be a redhead in
that that looks cos playable that I saw
pictures on possibly maybe look forward
to that so no that's right oh no awesome
well that's gonna be it from us here
guys we wish you the happiest new year
if you want to talk to us about anything
that we've covered this week or anything
else that we missed you can hit us up on
social media how there is that for you
you can find me on Twitter at Heather
ruse Instagram at a truce or twitch
twitch.tv slash Heather ruse I'll be
streaming a lot more cuz I got a ps4 for
Christmas
whoo I might be joining on one of those
streams we don't know maybe maybe maybe
otherwise you can find me on Facebook as
I anna-wade or everywhere else as
awesome Ayanna and I'm on tumblr now so
2018 yeah maybe they'll become - I don't
know no problem
[Laughter]
that's gonna be it from us here we'll
see you in the comments down
and next week until then beam us up
[Applause]
you